Jordan Peterson and Alex ' Conor AKA
Cosmic skeptic had a friendly
conversation about religion and they
began the discussion by sharing their
thoughts on skepticism its uses and
abuses as they came to an agreement on
the proper use of skepticism I started
thinking about all the young atheists
who needed to hear from this Canadian
British tag team and later I realized
how helpful it might be if more
conversations began with a little
groundwork work on skepticism because a
person's degree of skepticism is going
to play a significant role in the rest
of the
discussion so why not prepare the ground
a bit there's a link to the full
discussion in the description box let's
go through their brief exchange on
skepticism Jordan gets things rolling by
asking Alex about the name Cosmic
skeptic so let's start with this Cosmic
skeptic right okay so how do you come up
with the name and and and why the
conjunction and what's what what do you
think the advantages if any in
relationship to the emphasis on
skepticism Alex responds by giving the
official story and The Unofficial story
you can guess which one is true the
official story is that Cosmic sort of
implies universe space big thinking and
skeptic uh sort of situates me with
within a tradition of people who are
interested in interrogating their
beliefs uh to their sort of
fundamental uh fundamental grounding in
so far as that's possible and skeptic is
sped with a K because most of my
American most of my listeners are are
American British people like to be
different so they spell skeptic with an
sc instead of with the authentic
American SK like they drive on the wrong
side of the road and on the wrong side
of the car Alex's official story is that
he spelled it with a k for the the sake
of his American
viewers Now The Unofficial story The
Unofficial answer is that uh when I was
younger I knew a guy who was a musician
and started a Soundcloud account with
the word Cosmic in it and I thought hey
that sounds like a cool word and I was
starting a YouTube channel and wanted
sound something that sounded cool and I
thought Skeptics sounded cool next to it
and I spelled it with a K because I got
it wrong no you got it right by accident
but if Alex was wrong about that what
else is he wrong about
I see okay okay well well who knows the
actual derivation then it's a good
combination though because it it well
it's catchy so that's nice from a
marketing side but it also has
this it's an interesting illusion to the
combination of Revelation and critical
thinking that actually makes up actual
thinking a combination of Revelation and
critical thinking that makes up actual
thinking Jordan isn't talking about
revelation in the religious sense of
divine revelation I think he just means
that there's a vast array of ideas that
are presented to us and critical
thinking is how you process these ideas
the problem with being concerned with a
vast plethora of ideas is that many
ideas are misleading and wrong and so
you have to learn how to combine that
openness and curiosity with the capacity
to separate the wheat from the chaff
separating wheat from chaff that's
Jordan's picture of critical thinking
skepticism would be like a tool that's
used for winnowing so you get a bundle
of wheat the chaff is the casing around
the grain you crush the wheat to break
the casing and then you use something
like a winnowing fork to toss everything
into the air and the grain is heavier so
it falls back to the threshing floor
while the chaff blows
away so in this analogy skepticism would
be one of the tools like the winnowing
fork but there's a problem with
skepticism yeah and that's the utility
of skepticism I mean it can degenerate
into a kind of argumentative nihilism
that's the downside skepticism can
degenerate into argumentative nihilism
in other words if it's not used properly
it's just used to attack ideas and not
to separate good ideas from bad ideas
so if skepticism is like a winnowing
fork instead of using the winnowing fork
to separate the wheat from the chaff you
use it to stab the pile of wheat you
never get anything valuable out of it
and you eventually starve intellectually
and perhaps
spiritually but properly applied it it
uh it separates the wheat from the chaff
right and the purpose of that is to keep
the wheat the purpose of skepticism is
not to destroy positions you don't like
the purpose of skepticism is to
ultimately get to good ideas and now for
Alex's picture of skepticism well
skepticism can only ever be essentially
destructive because you're being
skeptical of something somebody's
putting something forward and you're
sort of responding to that with
skepticism and so for a lot of people if
if skepticism is the thing that you do
then you sort of end up chipping away
and ending up with nothing whereas
skepticism is really supposed to be a
tool that use it is destructive but in
the way that you might sort of um carve
a piece of marble you're intending to
get a statue out of it at the yes yes
well that's the thing to always keep in
mind is skepticism in the service of
something exactly yeah it's a tool it's
a methodological tool Alex uses a
completely different analogy but he and
Jordan have the same view skepticism is
a tool for Alex it's like a chisel
you've got a block of marble you use the
Chisel to chip away at the marble but
not just for the sake of getting rid of
chunks of marble your goal is to make
something so the statue would be a good
idea or even a complete worldview and
skepticism would be the tool that helps
you get rid of pieces that aren't part
of that good idea or
worldview I like both their analogies
especially since skepticism has become
so weaponized in recent years there are
lots of people running around with a
winnowing fork or a chisel and just
stabbing everything they see
and that's not what those tools are
meant for skepticism is extremely easy
to weaponize because it's very easy to
raise or lower your level of skepticism
if you don't want to believe in
something you can dial up your
skepticism so that nothing ever counts
as evidence if you do want to believe in
something you can lower your level of
skepticism so that anything counts as
conclusive proof to be fair everyone
does this to some extent once you have
your worldview whatever that may be when
something comes along that conflicts
with your world view you're probably
going to be more skeptical when
something comes along that fits in
rather nicely with your worldview you're
probably going to be less skeptical
again we all do this to some extent it's
a perfectly normal part of human
reasoning but there are two important
things to keep in mind one we're all
wrong about certain things we're all
right about certain things but we're all
wrong about certain things so when some
new idea is presented to you and it
conflicts with something else you
believe you want to keep in mind that
you may be wrong so that you don't just
dial your skepticism up and
automatically reject the new
idea two you don't want to dial up your
skepticism so much that nothing can ever
qualify as evidence against your
position if skepticism is measured on a
scale of from 1 to 10 let's say one
meaning you're so completely gullible
that you'll believe anything with no
evidence whatsoever and 10 meaning
you're so thoroughly self- assured that
you'll automatically reject any evidence
no matter how strong you don't want to
Simply raise your skepticism level up to
10 and then run around insisting that
there's no evidence against you who can
forget the Oxford atheist Peter Atkins
saying that even if God wrote him a
message in the Stars he still wouldn't
believe in God you know is there any
kind of evidence in the universe that
could make I mean if the stars lined up
to spell Peter please believe in me it's
about
time I put it down to Madness even if he
died and woke up in heaven he still
wouldn't believe well what would
persuade you I can't conceive of uh I
suppose even if I died and was
confronted with you know St Peter say
welcome to Heaven um I probably think I
was dreaming who can forget Richard
Dawkins and Peter beian agreeing that
nothing can ever prove God's existence
because any evidence can be explained
Away by hallucinations or by blaming
powerful alien tricksters if you even if
there was this this booming voice and
the second coming in clouds of Glory the
more probable explanation is that it's a
hallucination or Conjuring trick by
David Copperfield or something um you
know if you walked out and there were
these globes that were spinning around
that said you know I am God believe in
me or the famous cruss thing you walk
out into the sky and spells out in the
stars in different languages I am God
believe in me well again the problem is
it could be a delusion but the other
problem is you'd have to rule out
alternative explanations like the aliens
well I mean there could be an alien
trickster culture or something H we're
going to get those little humans any any
aliens who could actually visit us would
have to be so far beyond us in their
technology that they probably could
manipulate the Stars to to um spell out
words so what would what would persuade
you well I'm starting to think nothing
would who can forget Matt Dillahunty
admitting that even if someone he knew
was dead suddenly appeared to him and
shared information that the person
couldn't possibly have known apart from
something Supernatural Matt still
wouldn't believe in the
Supernatural so here's my question for
you I gave you that example of the
beheading I'm beheaded up here
everybody's out of the auditorium you've
already seen my headless corpse I come
walking out an hour later and you all
see me alive and I testify that I met
someone in heaven and they shared with
me a private conversation that they had
had with you that you know is is correct
now wouldn't our understanding that that
is Impossible by natural causes wouldn't
that justify you to infer that a
supernatural event has indeed occurred
yeah so I I like this question because
it proposes the very thing that never
happens
uh we we it goes to the extreme to say
ah if we could if if this happened would
you then accept that there's a
supernatural explanation and the short
answer is no I've never seen anyone
weaponize skepticism as successfully as
the new atheists a universe comes into
existence that's no evidence the
properties of that Universe are finally
tuned for life no evidence life
forms no evidence human consciousness
arises no
evidence hundreds of millions of people
are convinced that they've witnessed
Miracles no evidence near-death
experiences no evidence moral laws and
logical laws and Mathematics whatever
they are they're abstract and conceptual
they only exist in a mind and yet
they're real independent of any human
mind so where does that put them
no
evidence the new atheists run around
screaming where's your evidence where's
your proof prove to me that God
exists but they don't seem to realize
that all they've been taught is how to
play
skeptic and it's really easy to play
skeptic it's really easy to dial your
skepticism up to 10 and then say there's
no
evidence of course the people who taught
the new atheists to play skeptic are
people who've constructed a world viw
that's impervious to evidence so the
leaders of the new atheism dial their
skepticism up to 10 so that nothing can
ever prove them wrong then they program
a generation of atheists to do the same
thing and then they send these atheists
into the world to scream where's the
evidence we don't see any
evidence that's not the purpose of
skeptic ISM my friends skepticism is a
tool to help you get to the truth not a
weapon for hacking away at ideas you
don't
like some say that insanity is doing the
same thing over and over again and
expecting different results I say that
insanity is constructing a world view
that's impervious to evidence and then
running around demanding
evidence in short to all you atheists
and agnostics out there try to be more
like Al o Conor the cosmic skeptic and
less like Richard Dawkins the galactic
argumentative nihilist as Jordan
Peterson might put it
[Music]